what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch a movie because the
trailer for trolls 3 is coming out and we were
like there's no other time than now to cover
trolls it's been on the list for a month we were
talking about it a while ago who's we Roxy The
Strider Roxanne how are you you know what you have
a horror story about trolls growing up I remember
selling me this like a month ago he ain't really
sad I used to take the trolls and I would give
them haircuts as kids would do and then the Hair
Never grew back and that's how I learned my lesson
in life she was 17 years old when this went down
I said a kid under 18 as a kid yeah let's do this
ladies and gentlemen you know what to do leave
a like be sure to troll Roxy she doesn't like
another DreamWorks animated movie you did like
that movie didn't you but you said some stuff that
got you some crap isn't that what happened with
that movie you really liked the person you did he
really liked it but then I haven't seen the movie
yet but I was like I thought you really liked it
no listen I'm used to it and that's okay I'm not
gonna be everybody's favorite immediately but I
tend to grow on people like a fungus and everybody
loves fungus that's what I love to invest in here
fungus I used to say like a leech and then
somebody stopped me once and they're like you
know what leech doesn't grow on somebody right
there they suck off and they're feeding off of
them yeah you don't want to go with the leech
let me be your leech full-length Reaction watch
along so you sync up with your own copy available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon page thank
you all have joined showing your support
we also got a website for our patrons to
make it easier to navigate all of our posts
that's cool follow her at the world girls
um they're world-girling around all the
time all day every day let's get into it
[Music]
in the happiest tree lived the happiest
creatures the world has ever known trolls
nailed it one day the trolls were discovered
by a Bergen what is a bird you know you know
didn't know how to sing or dance or even
hug they were the most miserable creatures
in all the land ah okay they wanted
some of that happiness for themselves
monsters that's how you get happiness you eat
it foreign once a year every year Bergens would
gather around the troll tree to taste happiness
unbelievably dark they called trollstis [Music]
like Bowser's Palace yeah yeah it's a good call
whoa daddy wake up wake up wake
up wake up daddy wait [Laughter]
[Laughter]
ing
oh one day to be happy no one day to be
happy I'll give you a hundred dollars
if you can name what they're called trolls
the other people the Bergens I think that's
it bummer there is one amongst us who
has never tasted a troll Prince Gristle
I remember nervous my first Time same this kid's
movie Roxy be careful the happiest most positive
troll of all and they call princess poppy ooh
make me happy princess poppy no
what are you feeling oh I am yeah
it's fake fake I actually really like
the animation a lot 100 we'll find them
they replaced all their stuff with fake ones those
smart trolls they trolled
them no troll left behind
thank you King Pepe thank you yes
because the puddles are the problem
[Music] s
all right [Music]
take off your pants take it off [Music] foreign
oh what he sacrificed himself no troll Left Behind
go get him I think he's dead did he make it out
yes or no he's no I don't think he's dead I
think he makes it out he's gonna make it out
[Music] [Applause] [Laughter] that's
inappropriate can you acknowledge
that I was right you were right I'm
sorry is that why people don't like me
down here ungrateful throats I'm not
gonna lie so far so good I know that's
pretty awesome what's gonna make me happy now
come here son
nothing
you will never ever ever be happy
never ever
Savage this is already so much better than I
thought it was gonna be what were we
now sweet acoustic acoustic foreign
relatable music for the adults and now every troll
is free to be happy and live in perfect Harmony
that's why we hug every hour
yep every half hour [Laughter]
more cowbell
[Music]
whoa yeah let's Go soundtrack
don't do that it won't grow back
I'm loving the animation yeah
awesome
why is one of the trolls a giraffe
this is borderline hypnotic for me
don't stop Won't Stop the Beat
what's happening here they're all holding hands I
was like they were like they
wanted me to give you money
is that what you think of me they went
I was like Arena high five figures
giving you something good job I
could hear you from a mile away
is that Justin Timberlake I think so you always
ruin everything warning us about the Bergens no
I don't the Perkins are coming the markets
are coming it's like the British are coming
picked up on the truck
[Laughter] [Music]
smart history major you mean you're not
coming to the party tonight but it's
gonna be the biggest the craziest party
ever why does he look like that formed
Bergen's right to us I know you have happiness
inside you you just need our help to find it
poor guy I wouldn't be caught dead at your
party but you will be caught and dead thanks
for sharing your unique perspective on
things again Russell Brand how please
[Laughter]
Bible of every rule is in your hands I
sure hope the answer is singing dancing
and hugging because that's all you know how to
do can't believe you're gonna be Queen one day
you're such a hater [Applause]
this movie is just one music video after another
whoa [Music] [Applause]
is this what it's like playing with
trolls it was not my experience no
[Applause]
whoa [Music]
yeah great signal trolls why would you
send that up when you know the virgins
are looking for you I hope they're
called virgins like virgin yeah
not virgins
[Music]
wow this is scary and sad
[Music] puppy Creek
wow it kind of reminds me of like
those Leica movies like Coraline
thanks for throwing the biggest
the loudest the craziest party ever
they got really inventive with
how to use the hair yeah totally
and I know firsthand it doesn't grow like
that so you messed up as a child not realistic
that's the least realistic part of this movie
also I wish some of them had their ears pierced
you got a bedazzled one enjoy it is it coming back
we have to find a new home
mourn your dad we have to
we have to run
long time ago I'm not the king I once was yeah
you look like you became an addict or something
I have to at least try no you
can't go to Bergen Town by yourself
it's impossible impossible is nothing
Justin Timberlake's gonna help out
is he not aware of the situation that just
went I don't think so it keeps all the cards
I'm not going to your party
the party ver we just got it
attack bunker boy why is he kidnapping
her because he's a bunker guy
art will you go to bergentown with me and
save everyone what no they're your friend
ah they're your friends I'm staying right here in
my bunker where it's safe yeah I really only have
enough supplies down here to last me 10 years 11
if I'm willing to store and drink my own sweat oh
it's great that Justin Timberlake's the
most annoying character he'll grow on you
told her the party and I threw
it anyway and it's my fault
the trolls they were taking why don't
you try scrapbooking them to Freedom
Savage solid burn branch thanks anyway I
think he's going to become our favorite
character yeah for sure he's gonna have the
biggest Arc Wonder what your bunker what oh
it'll last them two weeks then I guess I better
hurry You Won't Last a Day out there and you won't
last a day in here oh she is manipulative Savage
please be careful don't worry dad can do this oh
what happened to her mom
we need the whole backstory
let's go [Music] I love this like 60s color
aesthetic yeah it's great princess poppy set
off to rescue her other friends confident she'd
make it to Bergen Town on her own Poppy's dope
Anna Kendrick has a great voice I know I love
her voice it's so young and fresh it's just
very cute you sound like a vampire me so
young and fresh and I can't wait to suck
we have very similar voices [Music]
the hairs like Venom or
Spider-Man and Venom oh [Laughter]
I'm not giving up today there's nothing
that is cool [Music] yeah
oh I'm marching along I Got Confidence wow I can't
think that way cause I know that I'm really really
gonna be okay hey I'm knocking oh my God
it's kind of talking about manifesting I know
[Music]
this is a modern tub thumping tub something
it's kind of like a Mario vibe to me too you
knock knock me over you knock knock me over
I will get back up again
wow this movie is crazy where's the dude
Justin Timberlake yeah I feel like he's
gotta come right no yeah yeah yeah c-o-m-e
obviously bro speak sure
[Music] thank you yeah JT know it
um
[Music]
what the hell yeah
oh [__]
okay this is what Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania should have been I love that movie
feels like the trolls are
pretty low on the food chain
[Music]
hahaha right on time oh right like you
knew I was coming we did we get to the
edge of bergentown without being
spotted which will then lead us
to the troll tree right before we get
caught and suffer a miserable death at
the hands of a horrible bloodthirsty
Bergen they're way too negative men
I love scrapbooking you don't seem to care
about that I do not care about scrapbook
it's a lost art do you have to sing
in a good mood Hakuna Matata I was getting Lion
King Vibes earlier they're a live Branch I know
it you don't know anything Poppy and I can't wait
to see the look on your face when you realize the
world isn't all cupcakes and rainbows because it
isn't it's so meaty yeah imagine everybody gets
to be like pink yellow purple whatever and you're
gray I think you might change colors by the end
of the movie you think the trolls have ability to
do that that'd be cool good night Satin [Music]
what's your troll name uh Grizzle that's a
good one yeah you could be rolly rolly not bad
growly don't hug him you gotta go hug him hug
him the non-contential hugs are not cool man
and he did not consent what trauma did he go
there [Music] the mix of songs brilliant I
don't sing and I don't relax shut up Justin
Timberlake I also like a little silence
[Laughter] [Music]
I feel like if I was in a bad mood this would be
beer every sleeping [Music] [Laughter] totally
[Music]
of Silence I'm not gonna lie guys I was
not expecting this video to work but it is
totally working wow thank gosh we came in with the
expectations that we did this is oh rule no honey
Buddies instrumentals a whole wisely
for one will lead to Bergen Town and
the others to certain death who said
that tiny person caterpillar me oh
hey guys how's it going do you think you can
tell us which is the right one you bet it's
about looks of them I mean who
were socks socks with no shoes oh
but outside it was weird
oh I know you'll do it but will he all right dumpy
diapers up high oh that's a perverted cloud don't
be diapers make Daddy happy that's weird come on
just one little high five oh no thanks I'm good
thank you for that demonstration really cleared
up exactly what I will not be doing Branch it's
it's fine can you high five yourself or is
that a clap that's a It's just sad [Music]
with a fist bump shark attack jellyfish
hand sandwich oh my God what gear shift I
like monkey in a zoo I haven't used that I've
never heard of that yeah I don't think hug
[Laughter]
come back [Music] [Applause] ah we're
here it looks like a cotton ball
I'm run Bergen Town laughs
oh I let's I'm going feelings I got sunshine
not for long the future is coming on
because they haven't been eating
the trolls you shouldn't need
your happiness to come from someone
else Greg shut up I need validation
he's not that different [Music]
even now they're positive why
are they singing so this means
we might actually get to be happy that's right
you'll never be happy no matter we must all
remain calm a com troll is a tasty troll and you
are a key ingredient in my recipe for Success oh
oh she's vicious by this time
tomorrow I'll be Queen true happiness
[Laughter]
it's like we all think our happiness comes from
somewhere it doesn't It's gotta come from within
they're not understanding that's a lesson for
Justin Timberlake as well yeah in real life
stop looking to Jessica Beale for approval
I'd probably look to her too though it was
hard off I was wondering yeah could you try
to be positive sure they're not only alive
but about to be delivered to us on a silver
platter thank you that wasn't so hard was it
Branch look they're alive and on a silver
Plus that's funny [__] Roxy it's clever it's
in enough yummy heads to feed all Bergen's house
if I were truly worried would I'd be willing to do
[Music]
oh my God are we gonna do this no
something stops it shouldn't we wait
for trollstis every day is trolls to swim
you have trolls yeah I guess ah [Laughter]
I'm nervous now they're actually gonna do
it but I think it's just a kingdom oh yes
this is dark do you think the trolls
slipped out somehow or something it
could poop it out like it already slipped
out of the taco base it poppy sometimes
people go into other people's mouths and
they don't come out that's what she said
poppy Poppy's a hero an innovative [Music]
you know man you'll give yourself enough credit
it's a bummer that his name is branch no poor guy
[Music]
what
she loves him
did you know this no no I did not know
this no there's been no no seeds foreign
but their happiness might be in
each other I guess I can see [Music]
oh sexy and my arms are [Music]
aggressive whoever this is is a singer
astute observation right well like Anna
Kendrick I know she she does my favorite
last five years of Pitch Perfect like this is like
a actual here we go sounds like that to me guys
[Music]
that was a good note though
sooner we can save Creek what hello
[Music] is it me you're looking for hmm
how could you possibly think Creek's still
alive I don't think he's alive I know it he's
alive and that's enough you're not smarter
than the writers Roxy I stepped on that hard
going [Music]
no don't be mean to her what if there was a way
troll King gristle put in his mouth I would do
anything to save him we can't get anywhere near
the king without him eating us how do you know
he's alive he didn't seem true you can what if
he thought you were this total babe what kind of
total babe would be dressed like a scullery maid
I smell it gravy if you get us Creek
and we'll get you a date with the King
wow this became a movie absolutely
different movie all of a sudden
disappear all your insecurities
just don't sing branch you don't sing in groups
I get it that was my best yeah that was
it took me a while but it's brilliant
because he was part of NSYNC do you guys
get it yeah yeah I got you I got you covered
okay
what oh how did that stop the
presence I was the one singing
[Music]
no he's The Bachelor I was so lost in song
I didn't hear my grandma trying to warn me
oh wow [Music] forever is going to start tonight
I did not expect this to happen as silly as this
movie is I legit got chills at that scene
I'm like that's tough my grandma's my girl
that's my person Grammy stuff moves me I had
no idea I just assumed you had a terrible voice
no no it was like an angels at least
that's what grandma used to say oh
whoa whoa what are you doing it's not hug time
I just thought you could use
one oh that's sweet everyone
but they always said the auto two movies
[Music]
yeah you are oh game ah I actually
thought he looked better before
whoa [Music]
she looks like a troll this is like
a whole other movie and I like it
was that 90s movie the girl with
the glasses brunette yeah yeah
uh uh she's all that I think you look fat what PH
that oh hot lunch total honesty from a total babe
oh your name is um lady glitter Sparkles serious
serious my name is Lady glitter Sparkle series
well Milady glitter Sparkles seriously join me
for an evening at Captain starfunkel's roller
rink in arcade yes you'd be delighted yes
you'd be delighted yeah you would be what
have to warm him up first do you
know anything about Romance of course
passionate about it yeah you know about
romance bro romance killed my father
[Music]
you are fantastic compliment
him back I like your back
your eyes uh ears stay are you okay
what's going on are you making fun of me
to be honest Eyes Two pools so deep I fear
if I dive in I might never come
up for knew it and your smile
Sun itself turns jealous and refuses
to come out from behind the clouds what
shine half is bright yes his smile and I do
have a nice smile don't I you don't use it yes
you do it's not gonna pop you yo yeah God
you caught on bro true happiness is possible
what do you think now put the troll in
there I knew it because you're gonna be
there as my plus one yes yes that auto
thing man what did you have in mind
[Music]
Ariana Maybe you would know better
than me I don't know poptastic
[Music]
huh
man they really went all out
here with these trippy visuals
your majesty [Music] meet the
lovely lady glitter sparkles
who remind me of someone foreign
just get my worthless scullery made to
get another place setting ready for the
lovely lady I want her right by my side hey
lady glitter Sparkle lady glitter sparkles
I'll see you at trolls this yeah take the
owl my dude oh my God Cinderella let's go
[Laughter]
We're Gonna Save Creek and life will be
all cupcakes and rainbows again up top
too slow wow that's hot yeah fresh
then how about just for tomorrow oh this poor girl
oh she's too good of a person this is why they
shouldn't have done it man you gotta be yourself
[Music]
good I feel good you know your
guys's voices aren't that far off
that's so rude I'm done with you
everybody hold on
hold on wowza wow no you
gotta be kidding me [Music]
oh oh thank God [Music] why don't you guys
take him out of there oh Avatar [Music]
is he not in there oh good I'm sorry poppy
we're too late actually our timing is perfect
oh that [__] this is what we call All Is Lost
The Darkest Night of the Soul save the cat I
mean every Troll and troll Village you'll
never find them not where they're hiding
hiding I could with someone
they know like this guy
he's selling us out no I don't believe it that's
surprising I don't want to die no don't eat me eat
someone else anyone else everyone else but not
me but that's not happened but we saw this part
oh dude has he really turn on them this is
like a metaphor for Russell Brand's real career
he doesn't know where the bunker is though
that is cruel oh that's what yeah oh my God
that is evil he is wow wow I feel like
there's some Tim Burton stuff going on
that's what I said earlier Roxy you're
just repeating my point earlier not if
you cut your point out of the video and just in
case I don't control the edit and make you look
better oh my God everybody I love throwing in
a pot thanks for asking are you being sarcastic
oh my God wow welcome to the dark side sarcasm
the cowards lie the world isn't all cupcakes and
rainbows better singular heart out I would live
for a cupcake right now oh starting crazy right
to these colors I told you she's hardened
but you guys don't get is that she's horde
she's hard what what is that
she's hard are they all turning gray
oh my God oh my God you better sing
your heart out what happens
when the hug watch goes off
they're all hard okay not one of
you kept the hope no she's the
leader they follow her there's
one with the kind of green nope
here it comes all right branch
she had earrings don't be discouraged
it's hard to take courage you can lose
sight of it all the darkness he's a singer
hug it's hug time oh
come on no switch roles what are you showing
the king is waiting get those trolls up there
keep singing it sounds like Lady Gaga yeah [Music]
it might be right Star is Born that's what that
those notes sounded like whatever I can't
stand you cause I will always true [Laughter]
I see your truth and that's why I love you he
does oh yeah that's right lay one on her buddy
afraid to let them show yeah yeah yeah good job
this is good this movie's good I don't care look
at him he's blue he's a Smurf I kind of wish she
turned a different color don't ruin it wrong okay
[Music]
I don't want to correct collect trolls
now don't cut their hair okay thank you
no thank you yeah good how to be happy really
now [Laughter] this is inside of all
of us right right sometimes you just
need someone to help you find I've said
that I still look for likes and comments
it's a fake out yeah she's
helping them Sparkle Girl
showed me what it feels like to be happy
it was actually just compelled by
what was happening but thank you
didn't want to leave you hanging
no are they gonna kill off Bridget
no he's gonna fall in love with her
and find out about happiness Bridget just ruined
her life save ours it's not right she deserves
to be happy as much as we do they all do oh they
all do she's got to teach them a lesson that it's
not about eating trolls Greg what did you do
you ate them you greedy greedy Pig oh my God
[Music]
what are they gonna do what's the plan here
guys you're gonna make her hair [Music]
[Laughter]
when you were with Bridget you were feeling
something weren't you yeah I was I
I just thought it was too much pizza
happiness yeah
no it's a lie your government is lying to you
here I am my belly empty empty and my heart
full that is what I'm talking about happy
it's inside you it's inside of all of us
and I don't think it I know it feel it
stop you are dropping the ball homie Jesus
I'm embarrassed I'm ashamed [Music]
sunshine in my pocket good soul in my feet
was this for this movie maybe it's awesome
nowhere to hide
wow I bet because this is 2018 right yeah yeah
totally yeah JT wrote this for this
I'm sure somebody else wrote it but
[Music] yeah yeah yeah that's move it feel it
in the shoulders yeah come on Let It Go [Music]
dude look at them go
taste of your own medicine
they just set her on fire oh my God dance
dance dance got this feeling [Music]
the happiest tree yeah yeah good catch
[Applause]
our new Queen
Poppy I know it's not officially hug time yet but
now that I am queen I decree
that hug time is all the time
give it to me whatever what's the
hands yeah the cloud is up high
[Music]
no way that was a surprise here we are
you don't know the situation Roxy now
we're going through before we started this
movie I spent like five hours telling her
I don't know if we should do Point Break or
trolls and I was like well we've had trolls
on the list for a long time and they have a
trailer coming out so I feel like it'd be a
good time to do it but we were also kind of
leaning towards Point Break It doesn't have
the worst reviews of anything I've seen but
does it have bad reviews because adults suck
I don't know I don't know like why would this not
be annihilating executive music producers no way
Zoey Deschanel which one was she we'll look it up
let's see if we can remember who the characters
okay you know Christine Baranski or whatever
that's probably the the woman the evil person
Gwen Stefani Gwen Stefani interesting well look
it up okay as a matter of fact we can multitask
right now all right do your thing I just don't
understand why this wouldn't have annihilated
to me it's a story about happiness obviously
it doesn't take a genius to follow that but
there's got all the elements it looks cool there's
friendship there's love great voices awesome music
a short good journey oh does the audition that
was Bridget whoa yeah who's the one who's saying
and I was like okay she's a singer oh it was Gwen
Stefani what do you mean wait was it Bridget when
I said that she sings Yeah that's what I said it
was Bruce's number yeah I don't remember Bridget
first saying she was singing about being in
love with the King oh okay you remember that
oh no whatever man I remember let's see if this
is everyone shut up the creatures in this and the
World building are kind of dope you said Timber I
was talking Leica which did like those Tim Burton
animated movies and they've worked a lot of
people worked on like they're like ParaNorman
I said Coraline we're referencing the same as how
weird is it that Netflix is recommending Rocky to
us after trolls uh I don't know something about
my algorithm on Netflix suggesting that I should
be watching Rocky after watching troll they were
like oh you feeling good all right they're trying
to figure out my taste right now they don't
recommend trolls too they're recommended so
watch Rocky there are three trolls movies uh I
mean the third one is coming out uh I don't know
this is trolls holiday trolls the beat goes
on ah dude it's like you know you know how
these animated properties are they have like other
little side flicks there's a trolls too for sure
that's out we're gonna have to we're gonna have
to do trolls too I was very surprised by how much
I enjoyed that movie because um yeah I don't know
there was something even when I saw like the when
you like hover over a video on Netflix you're like
oh yeah they're playing like a little bit of the
scene like this does not look like my taste right
now but it was kinetic funny and they had that
Peril whenever they come what were those called
the birken dots or what were they called the
burgers the Bergens Bergen yes what do you think
the sequel is what do you mean the Bergen dot I
forgot what their names were I added too much to
it you're just talking about the villains yeah the
Americans I think virgins would have been funnier
because we're all scared of a bunch of birds
done oh I'm with you uh I was really looking
forward to watching this movie um it's opposite
day I was not no I I just haven't heard great
things about it and then we looked it up on Rotten
Tomatoes and I don't think it was doing very well
there and on IMDb and all of that it seemed like
just a middle of the road animated movie and for
me animated is not necessarily my favorite genre
not that it's a genre but favorite uh medium so it
has to be a really great animated movie for me to
be like yes I feel like this was a really great
animated movie a really great movie yeah yeah it
was fun and yeah I think it has some of those like
marketing gimmick things were what I was thinking
in the first like 20 minutes where you could
just sort of take you could look up almost any
one of these music numbers on YouTube it kind of
felt like sometimes they were structuring a plot
around the music videos but yeah you did say
music video at some point I was like he's not
wrong this is like little Snippets of music videos
flash flash but when they did the music numbers
yeah I mean a lot of it plays on Nostalgia or
familiarity but the way they uh construct them
is so beautiful and dazzling and there are so many
parts of it that felt like I was like on shrooms
or something yeah just like it does feel very
trippy yeah do you think kids like this oh dude
it's a huge movie for kids it's a huge there's a
reason there's a third one coming out it's huge
well I just I guess because well it's going to
be coming out that means it's huge but the fact
that it's just not reviewed so well it maybe it's
the adults that aren't liking it I don't think it
really matters yeah I I don't think I'm harping
on that too much because I feel like it's getting
a bad rap for no reason like I want to actually
go tell people to watch trolls I need to start
defending I kind of feel like that even though
it's a massive film they have two bit let's look
up the box office that'll tell us if the movie
people are gonna be upset with me but I kind of
preferred this to Puss in Boots even though I like
Puss and Boots we're doing so well so well Roxy
with a message about happiness I think it's so
lost today on finding happiness from within and
having the people around you bring you Joy as
well I just feel like in 2023 it's all about
um romance only or about like well I I don't know
some insert other major big themes but happiness
gets lost sometimes and this movie is a movie
about Joy yeah I thought you picked up on the
very obvious message of this movie was surprised
like way faster than I did at the very beginning
about how we look for external things to make us
happy we look for circumstantial things it's kind
of like everyone in bergenville was a metaphor for
like Brendan Fraser's character in the whale you
know I didn't see it well there are people who I
could definitely be that yeah there are people who
did uh I know what it's like to be someone who
often tries to find happiness via binge eating
or looking for food or then you know there's other
ways that we can find ways to relate whether that
be you know a troll or not uh looking for food
they were looking for food too yeah they were
looking for I'm saying that you know like but you
can you can replace food with anything insert your
your thing here it could be social media it can
be another person uh just trying to find something
instead of finding uh self-happiness you know and
I think that is a really touching message to have
and is I thought I felt this movie was also really
self-aware of what it was that's another thing
that it didn't feel like corny to me because
it seemed very much even the whole thing with
like singing killed my my mom and it was a funny
moment Grandma I'm sorry I wasn't right uh no it
was Mom it was Mom I thought he's a girl it was a
grandma situation wasn't there because you were on
this whole thing about like loving your grandma
because I thought he said they killed my grandma
usually I remember things about
dead moms because I've got one
and I remember things about dead dances I got
one of those together we have a whole set of yeah
we're in the dead parents Cinematic Universe
um anyway that's fun for you guys at home when
you're watching a kids movie uh yeah yeah I don't
know where the parents were during this where his
mom was or her mom was you saw her dad talk about
poppy yeah oh yeah we didn't explain that maybe
they can reproduce without having that meat or
the second one who's made me say oh what Brent
Oh you mean it's in trolls too oh trolls 2 World
Tour okay so I remember this I just remembered
the situation in trolls through trolls 2 uh came
out like Peak pandemic when they were just and
they like we put on video demand and it ended up
being this like really huge Successful video on
demand movie oh really yeah where a video on a man
rebuy it oh okay you know the concept of buying it
yeah cut me off all the psychedelics that
we just watched I'd be really really going
for it maybe the maybe the plot is uh that lady's
back and she's like make bergenville great again
and feeling like I hope not and she's trying to
make bring it back to the old ways and restore
it I don't think it's a political commentary
Republic of 2020 at the time you know what I
really loved about this movie though is is the
happiness okay as somebody who is very happy
all the time no certainly not but as somebody
who believes people can change you know there's
that age-old outage Can people really change and
I think if you're somebody who's changed you know
the answer to that is yes and I really like in
this movie that the kind of the message at the
end it's not just the happy people who figured out
a way to be happy again it's the people who have
never felt happiness that realize that they can
feel Joy from within and and that was the message
that they that this is it can be new and different
and sometimes things take practice and I like that
you know I that they really experience maybe it's
too deep for this movie but when I was watching
it I was like they didn't just leave you know
we would have accepted it poppy laugh and then
we don't know what happens to this girl but they
teach everybody you know you can wake up one day
and decide I want to improve my circumstances I
want to improve my mindset I want to I don't want
to feel like this anymore and sometimes that takes
a little bit of practice but like it it can be for
everybody not just those in inherently happy
people that we see about that never seem sad
yeah those freaks yeah don't understand yeah you
guys are much a weirdos no one likes you there's
nothing interesting about it I just said something
really beautiful and poignant and I'm here to cut
the tension here on your beautiful volume Point
whatever okay did I grow on you like a fungus
I'm a really fun keep trying to keep
trying to uh redeem yourself from Puss
in Boots I'm gonna interject
here I like that movie I know
they trolled me on Puss and Boots
maybe they'll push me on troll
this stays in video yeah so um I feel like we
got to just touch on a couple more things then
we're good to go did I take us off track no no
it was definitely me this time normally I accuse
you but this is me today who's your favorite
character my favorite character um of all time
oh thank you for specifying I really okay um she's
not one of the trolls uh I I really liked Bridget
a lot Bridget was bombed she was the one I was the
most emotionally invested in imagine being told
your entire life that in order to have happiness
you have to eat the stroll and then deciding
to save the trolls yeah that's a religious
metaphor it's hard to put myself in religious
I'd rather not just the religious man oh
you told something your whole life and then you
have to use your own brain to realize maybe not
religion he's about to preacher had to do
thought that she was having her moment
and you talk you commentary for Olivia
whatever yeah I love Bridget too and I love
poppy usually my favorite character isn't the
main character but I loved Poppy yeah yeah I love
poppy a lot I mean I like Branch as well I think
the I think they had a lot of really funny quirky
characters that were constantly I like when movies
also do this like animation humor where it's just
like something snaps on screen basically and it it
weird [__] like that can just make me really
laugh like I love the reoccurring thing with
the it's like a cheap joke the glitter guy who who
had the auto tune on the whole time and they would
keep it in there and sometimes you'd have to kind
of listen for it but they would constantly have
it there so I appreciate that sound design choice
and uh yeah I even like the obvious choice but it
was a great choice I thought with the with with
the how Branch was like grayed out and you find
the color in life you spotted that I don't know
how you did that it's because we worked together
there you it was an alley-oop you pointed
out like why is he gray and I was like maybe
because he needs to find his color room triple
dribble pass yeah that's basketball for sure
yeah now you yeah I agree with that I also thought
it was very funny there was a you know from early
on there was that one line about the hugs where
it's like oh we hug every 30 minutes and then
one person's like I wish we hugged more often and
you and I both were like oh okay this is gonna be
funny yeah it was it was fun we were so on the
fence about it on the fence we were not on that
we were off the fence we were like no I don't
know about this or like it's only time to do it
let's go that's a lesson to us yeah no we got to
open ourselves up to happiness yeah and not live
by expectations yeah that's true and also just to
be decisive and listen to the your heart yeah and
then maybe in like go you know SEO analytical wise
it seems like the best choice that's why you're
hurting meant seo seo yeah yeah numbers clicks the
numbers and see what's there follow with mind and
calculation not from within that leads to failure
guys there was one other point that I was I keep
coming in my nog and then I'm like don't forget
to make it so weird I can Vamp while you think of
it that happens to me sometimes and then you like
just can't think of it but you know it's a genius
one is it going to be the one that makes the whole
thing foreign maybe it's about branch and his ark
perhaps it's about the evil girl and
the traitor troll wait I think I got it
actually that is kind of a bold
choice that they made like the
spiritual guy yeah and then it
kind of goes into your religion
but I know what they believe yeah that's actually
not bad but there is those people the more you
front does something it's like we get it yes yes
it was interesting to me that the movie took an
approach as they had that shift that happens where
it does become about Bridget and the king or or
the uh yeah the king Bridget and the king and
and that um yeah the whole storyline took place
plant the seed for this and we missed
it but at the very very beginning
um when they were focusing on the on the Bergens
at the very it sounds like a circle like some
Jewish the Persians Meet The Virgins I
like Jeff Garland there's the Goldbergs
um so yeah they had um that at the beginning they
focused on them and they get you kind of invested
in them as characters and and when they have the
kid being like you'll never be happy nothing will
make you happy you kind of want them to be happy
yeah yeah and I thought it was interesting that
they started off like oh I guess I because for
the thing to have the metaphor about the whole
thing with you know heat branches all blacked out
or gray whatever and then he turns and then he
finds colors in life and then the movie's showing
you at the very beginning that it's not so black
and white this this story that we're about to
watch unfold it's not just Bergen's bad Trolls
good and they don't know any better yeah they've
been taught one thing their whole life [Music]
I'll bring 2020 politics into what I think the
sequel will be okay you bring religion here and
we bring a bunch of enlightening deeper messages
for this movie that report are probably just
like I want to listen to That Fun Song again
totally yeah there was some fun songs though
like that uh one thing that you and I didn't
realize came from this got some sunshine we
gotta look that up before this video that must
be I feel like that one uh Oscar you think it
won an Oscar I kind of do what is this is called
Dance yeah Justin Timberlake Justine Timberlake
uh is it called Dance troll song Can't Stop the
feeling oh it oh I guess it is like a an actual
song from before yeah on you oh at least
on YouTube oh my God it is from Dreamworks
Animation can you look up if it was nominated
for an Oscar it feels like you don't think it
was oh maybe I don't I mean oh he opened the
office he played it yeah okay that's maybe why
I'm thinking that I remember no no you're
right yeah yeah yeah it was nominated for
best original song I remember there was something
about it at the Oscars when we started hearing it
I was like oh I kind of remember him coming
on stage with this oh that's amazing what
won against it I'm asking you to do too much
work right now okay all right 2017 Off 2017.
original song Oscars Oscars winner Oscars
yeah all right let's see city of style that
makes sense La La Land okay yeah
you're not going to beat that so
yeah and then you thought Lady Gaga
was in this but it was Gwen Stefani
yeah that's what happened they'll stay in the
video Yeah there'll be people being looked it's
not Lady Gaga it's Gwen Stefani and they won't
make it to this part in the video and I'll be
like well if they didn't make it they can go
themselves you can go troll yourself okay what's
your best troll line wait troll me for a second
I got nothing I feel like I said some things that
offended you during the reaction oh yeah like
what I don't remember but I was deeply offended
I'm very upset something about your singing
voice sounding like the King singing voice
my scene was dope that was messed up of you yeah
I'm sorry I'm getting this feeling in my body uh
uh into the raspberry side what I liked is
that I said troll me and this is what you did
I made you trailers you looked at me and then
you're like I'm gonna look away because there's
otherwise I'll throw something bad idea when
someone says something like that my mind just
goes for like not even a troll I I just go like
you're a dick or something I don't even I don't
even like think of it yeah okay you need G fuel to
function uh what okay I'll let you troll me since
you're so that's what I just did I need G fuel
to function yeah I do I work off of four hours
of sleep at night you don't even sleep these
are just straight up facts I wouldn't call this
a troll wow you're tired from not sleeping
because you work too hard boom it's micron
on that note people
it's Anna just go to the Puss in Boots reaction
to see how people throw Roxy on on that one yeah
and boot me here instead no it's not it's
not my goal to redeem you know oh I think
I've redeemed myself like each thing yeah wait
a good call back guys leave a like follow Roxy
on the World Girls uh you can check us on patreon
uh but before we go we gotta end this with a pig
uh oh do you know Adelia Chamberlain no but I I
don't think I know you Adelia let me know if I do
what I was just thinking when you said that though
was that I was hoping you would pick a Delia why
um because it reminded me of Adelia Bedelia
what is that I actually don't know first right
now I'm having a flashback of my childhood
Amelia Bedelia not Adelia Amelia Bedelia
was a character she was like um she was like
Judy she was like Eloise at the Plaza Amelia
Bedelia was like this girl she went through all
these things you'd read her books and [__]
her name is Amelia Bedelia so Adelia
is kind of like Amelia Bedelia combined
I'm gonna add on to your shout out to Delia to
make it more about you whatever I like a deal
I think you did a great job there I appreciate
your Amelia Amelia Bedelia bro I think you did a
great job and I appreciate it I'm gonna show you
what she's like while you do that I'm going to
say Adelia I don't know if you know this but she
was one of the people like you know how delivers
these subsections of schmodown are you listening
yeah what did I say I know you know how there
are these subsections of the smell all right good
all right yeah I'm a woman I can multitask I know
subsections there was like where they were like
maybe you guys I don't know what a subsection
of this I mean I mean the fandom like yeah
when there was like other community sites
and whatever and she ran one of those and
like there was when I was ending she had
one of the sections also I probably know yeah
you probably got like interviewed by her at
some point or whatever she was one of like the
most hardcore supporters of the shmodo oh that's
awesome I'm so sorry if I know you Adelia Amelia
Bedelia is a book this is what it looks like and
um that feels relevant she definitely knows your
personality two readings make sure to send me a
screenshot I really appreciate that you never
got to level two nope never did and Adelia also
um is a very talented writer that's
great and scripts novels yeah
I'm sure you've probably met her before actually
and well she you know like I'll say this since
since I first met you through schmoe down um
and I didn't really I wasn't a big fan of being
around Showdown to give you our love knows uh
I was a really big fan I thought you were gonna
say me so that was so much better of a turn that
could have taken I have a really big fan of being
around I don't really talk to you for a little
while huh I don't think I tried to pull it out
of you sometimes but you didn't want to answer
my questions what are you talking about yeah
the bold face lie so it's not it's a lie I'm
mansplaining your intentions so yeah the but
um oh yeah but and then especially with fandom
with the short on community I just felt like
for a longest time I didn't really feel like I
belong there and Adelia was one of the people the
fandom was were you over at fandom with me no The
Showdown Phantom oh this is the most convoluted
shout out of my life I was just trying to talk
about Delia we cannot get focused here [Laughter]
try to find a different
angle and say something nice
yes that was it that's awesome Adelia yeah she was
great she makes a lot of pots sure why not well if
you haven't checked out Amelia Bedelia please go
to Amelia Bedelia thank you Adelia all right guys
let's see I think that was really good that was
great special the video is now concluded [Music]